how would you like to make a partner
right now
oh no no oh no
oh quid pro quo sexual harassment
oh is that even consensual
hey legal eagles d james stone here
teaching you
how to think like a lawyer today we are
covering one of the
funniest legal movies of all time liar
liar
this is the first in a two-part series
as always remember to like and subscribe
and be sure to comment
in the form of an objection i'll either
sustain or
overrule your objections and while
you're there let me know what movie or
tv show i should do next
and stick around until the end of the
video where i give the first half of
liar liar
a grade for legal realism so without
further ado let's dig into the first
half
of liar liar my dad
he's a liar
a liar oh i i'm sure you don't meet a
liar
well he wears a suit and goes to court
and talks to the judge
oh i see you mean he's a lawyer
[Music]
i object that is slanderous and i will
take that little boy to court and sue
him for all that he is worth
uh you know or no it's not defamation
i'm just kidding marie do you have a
moment i'm sorry i'm very late it's my
day to be with my son
a couple of reporters want to talk to
you about your big win today
oh yeah how's my hair fabulous you look
great
so lawyers often have to talk to the
press i've talked to journalists on many
occasions to talk about
recent developments in the law and
things that are going on in my cases
because if you don't do pr for your
client no one will
or worse yet they'll talk to your
opponent who will give a completely
different spin
and you've got to get ahead of that to
make sure that your side gets out
fred it's your duty to present the
strongest case
possible the strongest case possible
consistent with the truth
will you let the judge sort of true
that's what he gets paid for
[Music]
so lawyers are bound by the rules of
professional responsibility and ethics
for their particular jurisdiction and
most jurisdictions
base their rules on the aba model rules
of conduct
and under those rules a lawyer has an
obligation of candor to judges and
juries in other words
they have to be honest to those judges
that they're up in front of so
under the rules of professional
responsibility no single lawyer can
lie to a tribunal and in fact if
the lawyer knows that their client is
going to lie
to a judge or jury that lawyer has an
obligation to not elicit
that information in fact the lawyer has
a duty to try to convince their
client not to offer false testimony
in front of a tribunal so there are
plenty of rules of professional
responsibility that prevent lawyers
from actively lying to a court so under
rule 3.3 of the model rules of
professional conduct a lawyer cannot lie
to a judge a lawyer cannot knowingly
elicit false testimony from their client
and in fact if you know that there is
contrary legal authority out there
you have to give that to the judge in
addition to the
legal authority that actually helps your
case so this attorney is absolutely
right
that there is a limit to the kind of
representation that you can use
uh for a particular client and you can't
actively lie
to a judge or jury to help your client
out regardless
of what your client wants damn it
i completely forgot oh what a surprise
you are a saint i should buy you a gift
you did
i always do the classy thing i think
it's inappropriate for a lawyer to rely
on his legal secretary or legal
assistant to get gifts for his family
however i will put in a plug for having
a good legal secretary they can
really save your life when you are
working really long hours
or you have a filing that is on a tight
deadline
they can really be the difference
between life or death in an attorney's
office
because they know your schedule they
know what's going on they know what
needs to be done
and often they're knowledgeable enough
to really help you out when you're in a
tight bind
any calls drawings clerk you need your
filing tell them it's in the mail
right she'll do it next week mr mckinley
oh man
tomorrow all right so one of the things
that drives all attorneys just
completely insane
is the deadlines that they have to
adhere to
when a court or a judge sets a deadline
the worst thing you can possibly do is
let that deadline lapse because
the courts have a very busy schedule and
you're at their mercy so if you miss a
court
set deadline you can be in a huge amount
of trouble you could miss
one deadline and that could be grounds
for getting disbarred or
getting sanctioned by the court and
really prejudicing
your client often these deadlines are
what's called jurisdictional which means
that if you miss that deadline
your case might get dismissed so
deadlines are this malpractice trap for
attorneys and i've seen
many many appeals taken where the
attorney just screwed up they missed a
deadline they
were late in a filing and you cannot do
what fletcher reid is trying to do here
and just
push off a deadline when the court is
calling you up and saying you need to
file something
that could be really important to the
case and you could get
horribly sanctioned uh if you fail to
adhere to that deadline so
that's the first time fletcher may have
been disbarred in this particular movie
i heard about your victory
congratulations you know you're making
quite an impression on the partnership
coming
oh that's right you folks are meeting
again soon
i've just been keeping myself so busy i
haven't even thought about it
most law firms have a partnership
committee that is formed by
a group of equity partners which means
that they are actual
partners they own equity in the
particular law firm and they're going to
choose
who gets to come in as another equity
partner for that law firm
one of the things that most people don't
know about partners in a big law firm
is that in order to become a partner you
have to actually
invest usually you have to invest in the
firm itself
so often when you're being upgraded from
an associate
to a partner in the law firm you
actually have to make a substantial
contribution
often on the order of hundreds of
thousands of dollars
to purchase your equity so they are
voting to let you in
to allow you to pay the firm to allow
you to be
a partner in that law firm hopefully if
you're paying a substantial amount to
become an equity partner in a law firm
it's profitable enough that you will
recoup your investment and then some
another thing that a lot of people don't
know about partners in the law firm is
that they often
don't get paid a salary they only get
paid a percentage of revenue or profit
in the law firm itself so often when you
go from an associate in a law firm to a
partner
you forego a salary and you only get
paid
maybe once a year based on the general
financials of that entire firm so
there's a lot of good and a lot of bad
associated with being a partner
but obviously fletcher here wants to
become a partner as
most people do in a law firm
wow this is good this
is really smart thank you only
well it's not true i mean does that
present a problem
so if the lawyer himself can't lie to a
judge or jury i
really doubt you can convince your
client to lie
on his or her behalf to the judge or
jury so
i think this is a violation already of
rule
3.3 uh the duty of candor you're the
victim here
the wife of a cold distant workaholic
starved for affection
driven into the arms of another man
seven yeah whatever
you're not trying to deny him what is
rightfully his all you're insisting on
is what is rightfully yours
and maybe a fraction more
i think you're bending over backwards so
ironically
despite them saying that whatever was in
that legal brief
that was a lie the argument that
fletcher reed is making here
aren't really lies they're just creative
ways of talking about the facts as they
exist so
his uh his rhetorical flourish is here
talking about how she's the victim
those can be true from her point of view
so
it's not necessarily a lie in and of
itself it's just a creative argument
that uses the facts as they exist i
don't know if that would win the day
against a prenuptial argument that's
pretty cut and dry
but so far what he's talking about
probably doesn't breach rule 3.3 yet
well we'll see
you're right mr reed i am tired of
getting kicked around
good for you thank you i am so
grateful i have an attorney i can trust
oh god
all right so let's talk about whether
it's appropriate for a lawyer to
engage in sexual activity with his or
her client
up until last year california was one of
the few states
that said that a lawyer could in fact
engage in sexual relations with his or
her client
so long as that attorney didn't coerce
uh or
force that client into that activity
under duress
that rule changed last year when
california supreme court brought
california into line with most other
states that says
an attorney cannot under any
circumstances have sexual relations with
their client
unless that relationship existed before
the attorney-client relationship
existed so at the time that this movie
was made it was
sort of okay for clients and attorneys
to have
a romantic relationship now that's not
appropriate
at all so that's something that fletcher
really needs to watch out for he
needs to be careful with uh with that
client
oh you are good you are
very very good
you know the cold case is worth a
truckload of money to this firm
if you win i guarantee you'll make
partner
in fact how would you like to make
a partner oh no no
oh no i mean i should quit pro quo
sexual harassment
oh is that even consensual really i
think that that could be considered quid
pro quo sexual harassment
she is making it seem like his
partnership
is contingent on some sort of sexual
relationship with her
so this is yet another example of quid
pro quo
sexual harassment showing up in
hollywood mixing romance
and an employment relationship is always
tricky
a jury could look at this situation and
say that
uh his promotion is premised on this
romantic relationship with her and thus
it's a quid pro quo
always always tricky never a good idea
you know the cold case is worth a
truckload of money to this firm
if you win i guarantee you'll make
partner
i don't think she can make that
guarantee a partnership committee is
just that it's
a committee of other partners and if
fletcher doesn't have the right numbers
or the right personality or there are
other problems then
there are all kinds of reasons why he
would not be able to make partner
even if one particular partner really
goes to bat for him
in fact while it is really helpful to
have at least one partner go to bat you
need to really whine and dine
the whole partnership committee in order
to make partner
[Music]
all right so fun fact about going to
council table in
a courtroom like that normally you
wouldn't be able to walk right up to
council table because there are a lot of
different cases that are going to be
called before the judge that day
and you may not be the first one but if
you ever go to a courthouse
if you look outside the door to the
courtroom
then you'll see what's called the docket
and the docket will explain
what uh cases are up for a hearing that
day and there will probably be a dozen
of them
at least and you'll find which number
you are
on the docket and odds are they'll go
sequentially down and leave the most
contentious
for the last one so that they get the
most time so
if fletcher has the first number on the
docket that day often
you will go and you'll just sit down
straight a council table but
before you do that you have to check in
with the court clerk and in california
generally you give them
two copies of a business card so that
they can attach that
to the sheet that talks about what your
case is there for
um once you check in with the court
clerk then you can sit down
if you are the first number to be called
on the docket
fletcher dana
all right samantha how much will it take
to put an end to all this 50
of your estate 50
with a prenup and proof of adultery
what's your case
our case is simply this
it is pretty normal for attorneys in the
same field to
have a prior relationship to know people
by their first name
and to talk with them what's odd here
though is that fletcher started out
this movie representing a criminal
defendant or presumably someone who was
a criminal defendant
and has now jumped into divorce law
which you don't really see very often so
it would also be weird for him to have
this prior relationship with another
divorce attorney
when it's not clear that he's ever
represented
someone in a marital dispute like this
all
rise for the honorable judge marshall
stephen
good morning call case number bd
09395 samantha cole versus richard cole
how we doing this morning council fine
thank you
and you mr e i'm a little upset about a
bad
sexual episode i had last night
so far this is exactly what happens when
the judge comes into the courtroom
and calls the hearing to order they'll
read the
case name and the case number so that
the stenographer can take that down and
make it part of the official record so
that
they have a record of what's going on
and he'll make
a little bit of small talk with uh
opposing attorneys before getting
the ball started uh and proceeding into
the hearing
first mr reed i see we're your client
your honor i would like a continuance
this case has already been delayed
several times mystery
i realize that's your honor but i would
really really really like a continuance
i'll have to hear good cause council
i can't lie
commendable mr reed but i'm still
waiting to hear good calls now do you
have one or not
no motion for continuance tonight
is there any chance of a settlement in
this case yeah so that
is right on attorneys can ask for
continuances all the time and often
especially in california state court
things are going to be delayed over and
over and over again so if you get to the
point
where the case is ready to go to trial
then the judge is going to want it to go
forward with
due speed so you can get a continuance
but as the judge has required here
you're going to have to show good cause
now i think
fletcher should have been able to come
up with good cause without having to lie
he could have said that he was just
brought on to this case
a few days ago that is generally
considered good cause
especially if the court approved the
transfer of counsel because her
old lawyer withdrew from the case so
that fletcher could come
on and represent her so if the court
presumably approved that withdrawal and
substitution
then he has a good cause baked in
to be able to delay this case a little
bit more
mr reed has made it abundantly clear
that he has no desire
i don't want to settle mr reid
you convinced me yesterday i'm the
victim here
i'm starved for affection i'm driven
into the arms of another man
seven yeah whatever with the story you
came up with i don't think we can lose
i want to proceed mrs cole doing unders
miscarried do we have a settlement no
all right that's good an attorney has an
obligation to
provide all offers of settlement to his
or
her client and in the first instance
fletcher reed tried to settle the case
without talking to his client which
would be
a violation of the model rules of
professional conduct which would be
cause
for disbarment if he went forward with
that so watch out for being disbarred
but ultimately he conferred with his
client provided the terms of the
settlement and she rejected it
she has the ability as the client she's
the one that's in charge of the
litigation
and she can choose to reject that
settlement and move forward that's
up to her you know why i pulled you over
depends on how long you were following
me
why don't we just take it from don't
talk to the cops here goes
i spat i followed you guys stop talking
to the cops
the more i fail to yield at a crosswalk
i change lanes in the intersection i
change lanes without signaling while
running a red light at speeding
is that all no
i have unpaid parking tickets
be gentle all right let's talk about
what fletcher reed should have done in
this situation with the understanding
that he can't lie just because you can't
lie
doesn't mean you have to tell the police
everything so
what i would have recommended and what
fletcher should have known
if he was a better lawyer is that you
don't have to talk to the police you
almost always have the right to remain
silent that's
in fact what the miranda warning is all
about you have the right to remain
silent now the police can ask for
your identification they can ask for
your driver's license
and your registration uh without any
real objection but that doesn't mean
that you have to talk to the police
nor do you have to answer their
questions so
generally speaking and there are of
course exceptions to this
but fletcher didn't need to tell the
police
everything that he had done he could
have just sat there silently and
let the police draw their own
conclusions now many police officers
will tell you
that if you remain silent during a stop
that may give them probable cause or
reasonable suspicion
that something else is wrong and that
they can do a more thorough search but
here
fletcher doesn't appear to have any
evidence of other wrongdoing except for
those old parking tickets it's not like
he had
a bunch of cocaine in the trunk of his
car and he didn't want the police to
search his car
so potentially the police could have
responded to his silence with
the assumption of reasonable suspicion
of some other crime but they wouldn't
have found anything else and they would
have only been able to write him
one or maybe two ticket infractions so
if fletcher had been a better attorney
he just would have stayed
silent given the police his id and
registration
and taken whatever ticket uh the police
gave him instead of making his situation
so so much worse you scratched my car
where right
there oh there
that's already there you
you liar you know what i'm gonna do
about this
what nothing because if i take it a
small claims court it'll just drain
eight hours out of my life and you
probably won't show up and if i finally
got the judgment you'd just stiff me
anyway
so what i'm gonna do is piss and moan
like an impotent jerk
and then bend over and take it up the
tail pipe
you've been here before haven't you so
fletcher points out that while he would
be correct
in suing this tow yard for the damage
that they have done to his car
it would be very time intensive and
even if he won he might never see the
money to compensate him for that damage
that's called being judgment proof where
even if someone gets a valid judgment
against you you have
so few funds that you couldn't even pay
that judgment even if
you got a court order so that happens
all the time where
sometimes the people that commit civil
wrongs or do illegal acts are the ones
that are least
able to pay for the damages that they
cause so
fletcher finds himself on the other end
of
the spectrum when it comes to lawsuits
where he has a valid lawsuit presumably
but he'll never see money as a result of
it which is
it's an issue hello judd stevens hi
fletcher read i'm scheduled to be in
your court in half an hour
oh talking to the judge sadly need a
continuance ill
am i ill that is the perfect question
for you to ask
please lie home for me okay i have never
heard
of any instance where a particular
lawyer was able to call up the judge's
chambers
and get the judge the actual judge on
the phone
that basically should never happen there
are times when you can call up
chambers and eventually get the judge on
the phone but in almost all of those
situations
you need opposing counsel present as
well for example
if you had a deposition where you
thought the witness was behaving
improperly such that you had to shut the
deposition down
and the witness would have to be
recalled well you could
threaten and follow through with your
threat to call the judge and report that
behavior
you'd put the judge on speaker phone and
talk about the situation that you're in
so that you can hash it out right there
and then so you don't have to call the
witness back to do another deposition
and incur additional costs but that's a
situation where even with the judge
present
you're going to have the other side
there so that you
have a communication between all of the
parties not just
one party and the judge these are called
ex parte
communications the communications that
take place outside
of court and i've never ever heard
of a time when an attorney could just
pick up the phone
and call the judge that kind of ex parte
communication
would be very very frowned upon and
would be potentially grounds for
sanctions because
the other side doesn't know what's going
on so that really should never happen
mr reed several years ago a friend of
mine had a burglar on her roof a burglar
he fell through the kitchen skylight
landed on a cutting board on a butcher's
knife cutting his leg
the burglar sued my friend he sued my
friend and because of guys like you
he won my friend had to pay the burglar
six thousand dollars
is that justice no
i'd have got him 10.
all right here's the thing about that
example about the burglar falling
through the roof
that is a complete urban myth
i hate hearing that example it never
ever existed
that fictitious example was created
specifically by politicians
in order to argue for something called
tort reform in other words making it
harder for
plaintiffs to be able to sue individuals
and entities for
harms that may have befallen them now
you can agree
with tort reform or you can disagree
with tort reform
but the particular example of a burglar
falling through a skylight into a
kitchen and then suing the homeowner
simply never happened it is just a piece
of fiction that was
created for argument rather than legal
precedent so
if you hear someone use that example ask
to see where that case came from because
i guarantee
that is an urban myth and not a piece of
judicial precedent
and on top of that if that example ever
did happen
in the real world there are all kinds of
reasons why the homeowner would
succeed i don't want to get into the
details of the difference between an
invitee and a trespasser and the
duty that one property owner owes to
another
but suffice to say there are a lot of
reasons why a homeowner would be
successful in defending a suit
against a burglar who had fallen through
a skylight
so just know that that particular
example is
completely fictitious and made up for
the point of
political argument and has no real basis
in the law itself
alright that was the first half of liar
liar next week we'll get to the trial
including the question of whether the
prenup and the marriage itself
was void due to fraud but now it's time
to give the first half a grade for legal
realism
there's a lot going for liar liar you've
got the real books that people use
in practice that it was filmed at
apparently a real law office because it
was right across the street from
my old law office and you've got some of
the dialogue that's pretty realistic on
the other hand
you've got completely insane things
happening
due to a curse that required him to say
only the truth you've got a lawyer who
doesn't know when to shut up
all in all i'm going to give liar liar a
b plus
not a bad effort but there's definitely
room for improvement and we'll see how
you do
next time in the second half all right
do you agree with that b-plus
leave your objections in the comments
and let me know what you think i should
review next
in the meantime check out this playlist
i put together that includes all of my
prior reactions including suits
better call saul and tons more so click
on this playlist and i'll see you
in court